beim neuen Bündnis Sara Wagenknecht
geht's nicht nur um ach mensch da ruft
du gerade an Sarah hallo ja du bist die
Chefin na klar ja klar ich lass dich
einfach im Ohr dann kannst du damit
korrigieren genau ja wir reden auch ganz
viel über dich SAR ist für eine neue
ostwestentspannungspolitik dass man den
Leuten in der Ukraine einfach mal sagt
entspannt euch doch mal und auch dass
man auf Russland zugeht und sagt
einatmen ausatmen den Angriffskrieg
haben wir uns auch anders vorgestellt
sag ist für mehr soziales und Ausländer
Moment Ausländern raten wir gar nicht
erst nach Deutschland zu kommen S ist
für den kleinen Mann die mag auch kleine
Männer außer der kleine Mann ist aus
Syrien wir wären uns gegen einen
autoritären Politikstil der letzten
Jahre Saras Stil dagegen ist ganz klar
diktatoris wir haben hier ganz
verschiedene politische Positionen
wollen Sie mal eine ziehen oh das ist
die Asylpolitik da müssen sie
weiterziehen das war's keine weiteren
Fragen SAR was machst du eigentlich
morgen ach W hat noch gesagt quality
time schon wieder Oscar